hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
these days there are a lot of people who
are worried about filter bubbles
right living in your own little bubble
only getting the sort of information
that confirms your views about the world
and
we've read about how to break out of our
filter bubbles etc but if you think
about it
the amount of information that is out
there to be consumed
by a typical person with access to a
computer and the internet
is literally overwhelming it is far more
than any one person can
possibly fairly look at we're all going
to choose to pay attention
to certain things and not to pay
attention to other things so there's
always a kind of bubble
in the sense that you can't literally
follow everything right
it turns out that manipulating these
bubbles manipulating
the way in which we choose not just what
political side we pay attention to but
the general question of what information
we pay attention to
overall is critically important for
figuring out how people work and believe
and act
in the modern world today's guest is
zayn neptufechi
who has become quite celebrated these
days for saying a lot of wise and smart
and correct things about the pandemic
and about social media and things like
that
she calls what she does techno sociology
and as she points out right here in the
podcast
it's really just sociology but
technology is just so overwhelming these
days you have to pay attention to it
zaynep started thinking about things
like protests and revolutions the arab
spring and the use
of information technologies like people
in tahrir square were organizing over
facebook and twitter
it turns out that the government's
response to this
is of course the first move is to censor
right to try to shut off the information
but because there is so much information
out there that's just impractical it's
just too easy to get information
what you can do instead is flood the
zone
you can sort of put out so much
disinformation that people can't
actually
find the correct information and this
kind of analysis
also works in other circumstances where
you're not necessarily in a revolution
so zainab has studied social media like
facebook and twitter in
everyday use as well as in revolutions
and of course
recently we've had this global pandemic
you may have heard of
so how do people get the information
they need to figure out what the right
strategies are what's going to happen
and so forth
it's a very fast-moving modern thing
that we all need to be thinking about
right what is the information we should
be getting
how should we evaluate it how do the
technologies of social media affect the
choices we make there so
this is an important as well as a timely
conversation
let me also mention that parenthetically
that despite me being a scientist and
zainab being a techno sociologist
we struggled with technology at the very
beginning of
the interview so for the first few
minutes the microphone quality is not as
good as it could be but we switched we
got a better microphone
we fixed our technology our sociology i
will leave to you to decide whether
that's any good so
let's go
z depth to the landscape podcast thank
you for inviting me
so you've described what you do as
techno sociology uh we haven't had a lot
of sociologists here the podcast we've
had one recently but
uh techno sociology that sounds
interesting when you know i took
sociology courses we were reading marx
and weber and durkheim and
so are you uh talking to android
versions of those folks or you know what
does it mean to do techno sociology
actually it's really funny i had to add
a qualifier to make it clear
that i was doing sociology
[Laughter]
sound really kind of um convoluted but
it kind of makes sense
so if you think about sociology and
obviously you've taken some classes
because you got the marx weber durkheim
the founder
we call them kind of traditionally
they're considered
three of the big founders um
it was born of an era of technological
transformation
right one of the defining things of what
sociology is doing
is trying to grapple with a world that
was changing fairly rapidly from you
know urbanization
mass manufacturing um
just the communication technologies
everything is an upheaval you know 19th
century
in the middle of a scientific and
technological revolution
and it is of course altering the way
people
live you know you have the rural to
urban migration you have cities where
people don't know each other which is
creating you know these sociological
concepts we talk about so all of that
technically speaking sociologically
speaking scientifically speaking
it is very much about understanding that
kind of societal change
but so here's why i had to add the
techno as
it usually happens um fields tend to
kind of start
becoming ossified if you will
a little um because that's what happens
to fields
and also there's a way in which things
get divided into the technology and the
sociology
so when i started what i wanted to do
was
to do the classical sociology the work
of sociology of understanding
how is the world changing as we get
these new kinds of communication that
alter our sense of space our sense of
time
how we can connect you know these are
very old sociological questions
but i'd also started as a sort of a
technical person so i had some
um sense of that side which is also
important like to understand
social change so as soon as i said i
want to understand you know for example
how the public sphere is changing or how
our notions our privacy are changing
because of facebook or twitter or phones
people thought i did um
stuff like user interface yeah like you
know what color should the picture how
we used it or where
should it be like people kept thinking
it was some sort of
technological work and i was like no no
it's not
technological in the sense that i'm not
looking at you know what kind of
button makes people click on yes i'm not
looking at user interface i'm not even
looking at human computer interface like
the hci that's not what i
do i'm looking at the sociological side
of it
and at the time that i was starting like
especially looking at things like social
movements
you could study a social movement
and not talk about the way they use
technology
uh the new technologies you could like
but it was changing
so many things about like how they got
attention how they organized there were
ways in which just the same way
like having moved to cities which is
some you know big technological um
shift in the way we experience space and
time and each other
had altered our social relations like
having phones in our pockets was
altering our social relations and i just
couldn't convince people
this was a thing to study so i made up a
name
to try to say no i'm not doing hci
and i couldn't just say sociology
because people are like then why are we
talking about facebook why is facebook
relevant to sociology and i'd be like
it's very relevant to sociology and i
was
so in a way i made a complicated
term to say i'm doing really
traditional stuff it's just the
traditionals don't
recognize this as the thing it is
and the new people think they're just
doing technology i'm kind of like no
facebook is a
people business it's not a tech company
it's a people company it's very much
focused on people's stuff right you need
um that you know the sociology side of
the psychology side of it
uh as much as you need the technology
side of it so that's
how i ended up with that
phrase so it's always been techno
sociology you're just sort of
recognizing that we have new different
technology today than we used to have
i mean it right now it's mundane but
when i made that term
up like uh it's been more than 10 years
the arab spring even hadn't even
happened yeah
right so when you started like when i
started going around saying i want to
look at how technology
digital technology especially is going
to have societal impacts
people are like say what like it just
sounded like a very bizarre
thing so it doesn't sound like a bizarre
thing now
so right now i wouldn't need to make up
yeah a term
but it's kind of got its little novelty
now and sometimes people will say how do
i be a techno sociologist or all of that
so i'm kind of like all right and it was
the name of my initial blog
so i kind of keep it but it's
i mean truth be told it's not a thing
right okay
that makes perfect sense but it's not
actually
necessarily primarily even technology
that you care about i mean i get the
feeling that in fact this sort of
systems approach is what you care about
more than anything else is that accurate
yeah that is very accurate like i don't
really care about
i mean i like the technology side of it
it's kind of cool i like like knowing
things about it there's a lot of
geeky things that is fun there but what
i'm really looking at is like how does
this complex thing work
right and in this particular case i was
looking at
how our public sphere and how
things like social movements and the way
we understand information
but i mean it's kind of hard to put a
single name on it but i just like these
complex systems and thinking about
how is this thing working how does this
thing evolve how do these things kind of
interact with each other in these really
messy ways
and just trying to think hard about that
and of course when the technology itself
is
a crucial input to the system it makes
sense to focus on that side because
that's where a lot of the dynamics and
the change is
happening from but that's kind of why i
was also
pretty eager and quick to switch to
sp not to switch i was always interested
in things like pandemics too because
they're a similar
interesting dynamic in you know
shuffling things around in complicated
ways as we have seen the last year
so that's the kind of stuff that i find
interesting can someone even say
i mean is there a skeptical case to be
made about
the new technological ways we have of
talking to people through social media
and the internet or whatever
are differences of degree but not of
kind you know we always were talking to
each other but now we're talking to each
other faster or is there really
some kind of shift that is undergoing
and really changing right so is more
different
um is i would say of course
in some ways yes so what you have
is um i mean in some ways it's a break
that comes from the invention of writing
right
for before writing all you have is the
ephemeral speaking
right you do not have a way to um
separate the speaker and time and space
right you can only speak
in that moment in that place to someone
else and you have all the sort of degree
the
greeks are interesting partly because
they're that shift from oral
to uh you know written society and you
see them like they're very obsessed with
the arts of the rhetoric and
you know that kind of oral persuasion
and all those things so you see
um the big break is writing
where for the first time you can
separate the
sort of the words of the speaker from
the speaker
but then you know it kind of gets um
interested in all sorts of different
ways we have the printing press which
kind of
automates that process so you can have
texts that are uh available in mass then
you have
something like telegraph that is for our
purposes
instantaneous it's not you know
instantaneous to a physicist but for
human purposes
it is instantaneous communication which
is another big break right before the
telegraph
um you are still limited to the speed
of your messenger you know if it was a
pony express or a pigeon
i guess you could do things like you
know flash uh
smoke signals or mirror signals like
that but those are
fairly limited to how far you can get
like that so you have the telegraph and
then all of a sudden
you have things like the telephone where
the
voice itself is instant
and then you have so you have i think in
some ways
of course we always spoke to one another
right you know we spoke to one another
ever since we had any kind of language
in other ways starting with writing we
have had
ways in which how
that speaking and time and space in our
bodies
existed or did not exist are being
reshuffled in very interesting ways and
every time we do something like that it
has huge
consequences right like all of a sudden
um
you know you have the way wars are
fought changes because if you have a
telegraph
you know before in in this u.s civil war
you had people fighting because they
didn't get the word that it had ended
you have all sorts of different ways in
which the whole aspect of
you know immigration changes because
people would just go to another country
and never hear again
except maybe you know a letter once a
year and now you're like
that's what's happening all day so those
are very different i think um
things so they're not like
everything that's in kind is also in
degree usually in some way so this is
i think a case of a more is different
okay in that it affects what
happens to us and how we live
but it doesn't make us different kinds
of people so let me try to say it this
way like you could plop someone
from the pleistocene or the late
pleistocene maybe and they might be able
to adjust
you know so it's not like you're a very
different kind of species um
in terms of how what we like to do we
still
like to connect with people we care
about status we
are social right so we don't really do
supe
we don't turn into some sort of um
alien creatures yeah but the game board
on which we are
doing those things you know where we're
acquiring status where
we are getting our information all those
things do
change there's actually a great uh i
think it's a danish tv show
called be foreigners about exactly this
they bring you know there's time travel
and they bring people up from
the police to scene and uh they adapt
pretty well actually you know with a few
cosmetic changes we would like they
would do pretty well we're not
as different as we think you know they'd
have to adjust to
you know a few technological tricks and
new stuff
but it's yeah you could live from the
point of view of complex systems though
is there
something about social media that
enables people to sort of broadcast very
widely but at the same time not be part
of some
giant centralized institution is that is
that kind of a new thing
well i it changes the gatekeeping
mechanisms right so before if you're a
social movement in the past you try to
get attention from television
if you didn't get on television or
newspapers you kind of
could do a huge thing and
like nobody heard about it and didn't
have an impact because attention is
really important like there were
cases in the middle east of sort of a
couple even couple years before the arab
spring you had these incidents where
there are these mass
strikes and little uprisings here and
there in little towns and they kind of
die out because
um there just wasn't enough saturation
of
the cell phone that's going to record it
the facebook network that's going to be
able to spread it and you know they're
just sort of surrounded town and there'd
be censorship and all of that
so right now you can get attention
without approval of the traditional
gatekeepers
that doesn't mean there's no new
gatekeeping mechanisms you know as we
found out
even the president of the united states
can be de-platformed
so it's not like there's no gatekeeping
there's new kinds of gatekeeping you can
be kicked off these things they have
various algorithmic
methods that um amplify certain things
so if you're
friendly to the algorithm in what you do
uh
if you can kind of um there's all these
other things if you sort of
already get have a lot of followers that
will help you
amplify things so it's not like the
gatekeeping has disappeared that it's
all
flat it's just not the old kind of
gatekeeping
and that in turn uh changes what
you know we have as common knowledge
what people think is the norm
do we even have a common knowledge like
do we have
a way in which we construe what's
happening and because
if you think about it you don't really
know what's happening around the world
it's
somebody tells you yeah right you don't
see it all
so you have sources you trust news you
follow so you have
a mental model of what's happening
um right outside your immediate
visceral experience that comes through
mediated sources for you and that's fine
like that's true for everyone
so if you look at like mid 20th century
those are very centralized for the
united states like they come
through you know big broadcast big tv
big media
right now it's really fractured so you
have an epistemic fracture so these are
i think very interesting things
because if you have an epistemic
fracture in your
society you know you can have a very
different mental model of what's going
on
in one portion of the society and
you know the other portion has a
completely different view of what's
going on
that's a different kind of question than
what we had before
right uh so i think those are the ways
in which these things are
changing how we live through things
including through pandemics or political
crises or anything we go through
one of the great things about learning
something new is that not only do you
have new knowledge
but you have a sense of accomplishment
for having attained it
one of the best and most fun ways to do
that is with a subscription to the great
courses plus the great courses plus is a
streaming service that offers over
13 000 audio and video lectures
from a wide variety of topics and with
the great courses plus
app you have the convenience of watching
from your phone your tablet or even
streaming to your tv
i can recommend with a little bit of
bias my own course on the physics of
time
if you liked last week's podcast episode
about the neuroscience of time in my
great courses plus course
i talk about neuroscience but also about
the physics of time the philosophy of
time and the cosmology of time
so sign up for the great courses plus
today to start your 14 day free trial
and for a limited time
mindscape listeners save 20 off an
annual membership
only through the url the great courses
plus
dot com slash mindscape that's t-h-e
great courses p-l-u-s dot com slash
mindscape
there was something that i read in one
of your pieces that crystallized for me
something that i've been thinking about
for a long time the idea
that uh in the modern world
there is no shortage of information
right there's a lot of information
floating around
what there is a difficulty in is
figuring out what to pay attention to
that you had a line that attention
matters more than information i'm like
yes finally as i've been thinking i
think that the
very first uh uh intro i did for this
podcast series two years ago i made a
similar point to that and in fact
there's another line about how
censorship works by drowning us
in too much in differentiated
information rather than keeping
information from us this does
sound like something new as far as i can
tell yeah
so that part is new so i'm gonna um
there's uh i think the first sort of um
formulation that i really like about
this
is uh herbert simon and it's about like
1973 or something and
he's basically pointing out that
in a society where you have
a lot of information the thing that is
precious
is that which information consumes which
is the attention right like so you don't
you have you no longer have a scarcity
of
information and the moment you don't
have a scarcity of
information you have a scarcity of
attention
and so it becomes the filter that's
important not
you know the information and in such an
environment like in
when i was growing up in turkey the way
they would um
censor things was very traditional
censorship they would
you know they'd have a military coup and
we have them a lot
so it's kind of we have like
well-established best practices
quote-unquote for military coups
and the traditional best practices would
be you surround the radio station
you surround the tv station you take
over the radio
station if you're in the 60s the tv
station if you're in the 80s and then
you control the broadcast
right this is the very traditional
method of controlling information from
getting out at all
now of course um i lived through another
coup in 2016. i just happened to be in
the country
uh and we had another one of them and
there they did
even try to go to a few of the tv
stations
but like i was looking at my phone not
the tv like i saw
everything was happening through the um
you know whatsapp groups and other kinds
of information sharing
and they never got an information
monopoly
over the country uh so the scent the
sort of the that kind of
you know you can shut down a few tv
stations it doesn't really matter
so in such an environment if you really
want to censor things you can try to
completely shut down the internet
but that's a very like you can't really
have a modern economy then like you
can't really be
a world in which you just shut down the
whole internet because there's all this
other stuff that's going on including
the just the regular socialization
including economic activity
so the way a lot of places have figured
out how to do censorship
is by information glut you drown people
in information in claims
uh questioning the credibility of
whatever you don't like
claiming things are you know fake hulks
uh other kind of things so you base or
distracting
uh creating distractions uh you know
just when something important is
happening
you know create some other fall
controversy so these are
managing attention right none of them
are really
blocking the crucial piece of
information
from being found by somebody who's
focused on finding it but they are
making it essentially more difficult to
even identify
the crucial piece of information amidst
all the you know cacophony
and also like for enough people to focus
on it and say because information by
itself isn't powerful it's if enough
people take it seriously
and decide that this is um the crucial
information we need and do something
about it you know that kind of
so you can break those chains you can
break the chain between
information and action by not by
removing
the information but just surrounding it
and things
in an environment that makes it useless
to the hearer because you can't tell
what's going on and i think that's the
modern form of censorship that
and i wrote this in my uh book that came
out before donald trump was
elected right i was kind of like um
working off from
examples around the world of other um
sort of authoritarian and other new
populist ways of
um sort of creating
obstacles to uh focused
information and attention on what was
sort of important and relevant and then
donald trump got elected and everybody
was saying oh these are you know this is
what he's doing and i kind of was like
yes
and that's not really unique to him
right this is something that we have
seen around the world so i didn't really
have some sort of
crystal ball uh to say you know
this is what he's gonna do uniquely
before he did it i was just looking
around and
you know he was one more in a pattern
and if every claim that you can imagine
is out there in the media
and every counter claim is also out
there then
you can see i'm not a professional
sociologist but i'm guessing
how you can have these little groups of
self-sustaining epistemic communities
that are sort of
completely divorced from the mainstream
and and that might
feed into polarization and fracturing
more broadly
but so the thing is it's uh even more
than that
is that so if you want to get people's
attention
like um traditionally sort of if you
just think about human beings
uh we like to think of ourselves as
these wonderful cognitive creatures
and there's no doubt like you know we're
fairly smart apes for as
these things go but we are still social
animals
right and some of the most motivating
things for us
are things that pertain to group
belonging
right which group we belong to our
status within that group
and um which group is the out group
right so that's like the traditional
in-group out group thing
so if you really want to get attention
in a media environment where
you can kind of play with these things
tribalization is your best bet for
getting attention
right you know if you want to get clicks
uh sort of the culture wars and
dr seuss and all those things are really
going to get people's attention because
it's a way of
delineating us versus them
and us versus them for a social species
like that's a very very important thing
because you know we want to find our
group and we want to sort of figure out
who's the other group
and we have these platforms like
facebook and the others that are
um twitter all of media basically
that are financed by
getting our attention and then selling
it to advertisers
so to do that they must first keep us on
the site
and to keep us on the site you find
their design
really encourages this tribal dynamics
now it's not
just hating other groups it's also
bonding with your own so you find like
the
like the facebook groups thing it's like
oh you find the people that think
like you but that's that's the flip side
of
um finding people you don't like because
that demarcation process that in group
out group like you can't have one or the
other without the other
right if you're a fan of one team there
has to be some other team
that your team is playing that you can
cheer for right this is just
very very basic and things like you know
fans
of sports team and stuff like that those
are sublimated
um usually not dangerous ways of in
group
out group processes we just find a team
we cheer for it you know we don't
normally go and
murder the other teams uh fans normally
although it does happen occasionally but
if you kind of think about it like a lot
of things we think about the nationalism
uh tribalization in within the
polarization within the country the
um all of those things are in group out
group processes so
now we have at a global scale these
major platforms that are using
what are very basic social species
dynamics to grab your attention to say
here come find the people that
you identify with and then also
sort of polarize against the people
that's the out group
which is the basic thing and you see
they feed into the polarization what
they will
say in response is that we don't create
these dynamics
these are human dynamics which is true
but they also have a business model that
very much
amplifies these dynamics i kind of see
them like you know
like a ice cream company that's serving
ice cream for breakfast lunch and dinner
and saying we didn't invent
ice cream the human appetite for sugar
fat
you know because that comes from your
evolution right where our appetite for
calories and sugar and fat or salt comes
from
the scarcity in the past so it totally
makes sense that we have an appetite for
it
but they have a business model in which
they keep giving more of it to you for
breakfast lunch and dinner
so it's like they're um symbiotically
merging with what are human social
dynamics to keep us
on their site well this makes me think
that i number one i like ice cream
and number two i i think it's great when
tiny groups of people who otherwise
would never have found each other can
find each other
online so is there is that trade-off
inevitable or is there some way uh
programmatically to allow people to find
themselves and be part of the in-group
without demonizing
part of some of the issues are like how
large are you gonna make the ad group
right like or
how large are you gonna do the scale so
if for example
facebook groups was limited to 250
people
or 150 people right something like that
and if you wanted to go larger
there were these other requirements of
moderation and this and that or
i'm just making up something but if it
was limited in scale
it wouldn't have the same effect because
you would probably find
a different dynamic or if like
but i'm not saying this is something to
be done i'm just kind of saying that
once you allow
these big groups to come together in
this kind of format
unless you have something pushing in the
other direction
it's going to polarize now traditionally
because of history and because of the
way advertising work
traditional media would try to be in the
center
because you they wanted the scale and
they wanted
a broad sort of range of readers
so that sears could advertise with them
right like sears didn't want to be
on the left or the right or something
see the sears wanted to reach a majority
of people
because you didn't really have the kind
of scale you could have
uh without bringing people together
whereas right now you can bring people
together on a platform like facebook
advertise to large numbers but you do
not have to
bring them together ideologically
towards a center
the way traditional broadcasters would
try to do they can all be in their
little groups saying very different
things
they're still on facebook right so in
the past if you read the wall street
journal
or the new york times um you're all
reading the same newspaper
whereas right now you can have two
billion people still be on facebook so
you have the scale
but they're not reading the same thing
that's a very different
like way to get scale the first one
requires some sort of ideological
centering
to get to that scale whereas the new
york times or the wall street journal
model like they're not exactly at the
center of course but they're trying to
sort of
apply to broad categories whereas
facebook does not have to do anything of
the sort it can apply to people across
all sorts of political views because
digital technology allows it to be
different screen by screen the newspaper
cannot
morph like the paper cannot morph
into a different paper depending on
who's purchasing it
that's a big difference it's static like
it's physically cannot just morph every
time somebody picks it up
where something digital can is there
those are very changes you know
is there any way for us a researcher or
a watchdog
to see what ads are being targeted at
different groups on facebook
well people have called for things like
that and right now
we have even some level of transparency
but you know once you got to that scale
if
transparency itself isn't getting you
everything you need if nobody's looking
it's kind of like saying we should have
ingredients
well fine if the ingredients are
published but nobody's checking what's
in them
you know and you got titanium oxide and
a bunch of baby food and nobody's
looking at it like just the transparency
alone is not a bad thing
but like who's looking at it who would
even like
would would we even agree who should
look at it right these are things that i
don't think we have
resolved at all uh as a society and i'm
not even saying
i i sometimes because i do the critical
thing it's not like i'm saying
this is terrible we should go back to
the past
because um there were so many ways in
which the past
wasn't great uh and also it's not coming
back
like even if you liked it it's not
coming back it's just
like because that's not how the world
works
and there was a lot of things that were
like brushed over and
censored and hidden and you couldn't
find people like you and you couldn't
like
there were ways in which all sorts of
people were isolated because they didn't
you know you might have been living a
rural place and not have access to
you know you might have been a gay kid
without anybody
openly gay around you and have no clue
and now you can go
on social media and find some people who
can say okay you know this is like
there's lots of us
i'm just giving a small example or you
could just have one hobby and not have a
single other person or you could just be
like there's all these things in which
the ability to find
each other is a good thing the trick is
though it's
not confined to things i like right
right this is also true for white
supremacists right i mean if people who
like
um you know something sort of geeky or
cute and something i like can find each
other that doesn't mean the same
mechanism doesn't operate for the white
supremacist so the
error is treating it like a pony that is
supposed to do what you say
and then getting disappointed because
that's not what it is
and then going from some sort of utopian
sort of this is great i find people i
like to
oh wait this is terrible other people
find people they like
without realizing well those are kind of
the same
dynamics and the question is like how
can we approach this and say
we can do something um better
to to sort of manage this transition
because it's a major transition
when you're hiring new people it's a
matter of not just who you say yes to
but who you say no to
it helps a lot when you can narrow down
the list to only good choices to begin
with
so you're not choosing between good and
bad but between good and great
that's what you get with indeed indeed
is the job site that makes hiring as
easy as one two three
post screen and interview all on indeed
indeed makes connecting with and hiring
the right talent
fast and easy with tools like indeed
instant match
giving you quality candidates whose
resume on indeed fits your job
description immediately
and indeed skills tests that on average
reduce hiring time
by 27 you can choose from more than 130
skills tests or add your own
then add your must-have requirements so
that you only pay for applications that
meet them
get started right now with a free 75
dollar sponsored job credit
to upgrade your job post at indeed.com
mindscape get a 75 credit at indeed.com
mindscape offer valid through june 30th
terms and conditions apply
well and another aspect of this sort of
double-sided coin business
is you've made a point of this whole
apparatus pushes us towards a lower
trust
society where we're more skeptical of
institutions and so forth and
that's definitely what i can see both
sides like in some sense i want people
to be skeptical of institutions but
when it becomes just a way to ignore
anything you don't want to hear then
that would be bad
yeah so this is something like i i
haven't really had a chance to write
about this
uh but most conspiracy theories
are not driven by ignorance
but by a sense of curiosity
and wanting to figure things out without
guardrails
like if you kind of go through these
conspiracy sites like they're citing
articles and
like there's all these little collect
the dots and like you
could almost squint and see
well they're trying to do some sort of
leg work for
um what you'd call the scientific
process except there's no guard rails to
keep them from you know getting lost in
what they're claiming or what they're
reading you know it's because
it's so that's the thing is skepticism
itself isn't empowering but
don't be a skeptic is nonsense because
skepticism is
how we do science it's how we make
things happen it's how
we question and if you look at the
history of
medicine or something like that there's
so many things that were
considered outside the mainstream
till they weren't because the mainstream
was wrong
the mainstream was and in fact they were
wrong because they were like stubborn
and then you know new things happen so
you do have these things you do have
this skeptical outsiders who come in and
say the mainstream is wrong
but that doesn't make everybody who
thinks they're a skeptic galileo right
like there's a lot of people who are
they all think they are but there's a
lot of people who um
think they are you know the new galilea
and they're just cranks or they're
they're they lost the sort of they have
no connection to reality
and or they're grifters but of course
the problem is
how do you tell them apart who
designates
uh which side like i have my preferences
for what i think
are the correct skepticisms and what is
what i would consider conspiracy
theories but those are
like mine and like that's not everybody
else's so if you're gonna have some sort
of
you know ministry of truth telling us
which ones are conspiracy theories
that's not really gonna easily work
uh because i think the pandemic has been
an eye-opener that
many central authorities even with the
smartest people can get things wrong
right so somebody needs to say well you
got this wrong
but there also has to be a process i
think this is like a new appreciation of
um there's no checklist sometimes you
sort of
teach kids science with the sort of
there's a little wheel and there's a
hypothesis and there's data and there's
this and you know you sort of go through
it and that's not how
it really works there's like a whole
cultural institution it's embedded in
and if it's full of people trying to
kind of get to
a more precise understanding of the
world with a lot of guardrails it kind
of works
but if you don't have all those culture
and the institution and the guard rails
the same
sort of little wheel of hypothesis
data go back it just isn't going to work
and that is um kind of hard to
put in a sort of um that's the right
word
uh schematic a little algorithm
it's not like a checklist like there's
no critical
uh thinking checklist there's no way to
be a critical thinker
i think without a lot of substantive
knowledge in the area
and acculturation into a group of sort
of people
and the discussions and debates
but that doesn't make those people the
final authorities either
because as we know it's a human process
and it does
go alright and there are egos and weird
things
know any academic can tell you all sorts
of stories of
quirky things that shouldn't have
happened or
just egos that got in the way of things
but on the other hand
on the whole the enterprise does seem to
work
it does but you're right that there's no
checklist people are always asking me
for a checklist
you know what i should trust about
science on the internet or whatever i'm
sure people are asking you for the
checklist also
yeah all the time and as you say there's
just way too much information so
not everyone is going to go back to the
original published refereed articles
right that's just not
uh plausible enough and if they couldn't
understand them if they did
but there is even without a checklist i
want to say and i'm not saying this with
any confidence at all but i want to say
that there's still a way to sort of get
a
feeling for the credibility of different
sources you know asking whether or not
they have a track record asking whether
or not they are
uh being humble about what they're
saying like you know they're they're
delineating the limits
of their knowledge versus just
bombastically claiming to have solved
everything
uh i think that even though we can't all
be experts in everything we
we're forced it by the modern world into
a situation where we have to judge
things so we have to figure out ways to
do it
right so i think there's some of that
where you're um
there's a sense like that but even that
sense doesn't come
without some leg work like i'll give you
like an extreme example i think
uh what's the name of the um there there
was a
company um that
claimed to have a very large scale
um hcq study by
um comparing i think 150
hospital records something like that
and hcq is um
was something that the president
of the united states was erroneously
claiming that um
or whatever coveted very early it was
something like that
so okay so it got stuck in a very very
um
polarized debate because of that and of
course the thing you want to look at is
like where is the
you know peer review of science whereas
the studies where the forget the periods
you know where's the preprints and
things like that and this was kind of
early
in the epidemic pandemic
and we had a few papers come out
that were um claiming that
there was a big study uh
from a company called sergiosphere that
was comparing like hospital records in
150 countries that showed
it claimed that the hcq was harmful
like really drastically harmful uh
not just mild or anything it was like a
very large size effect
and immediately people jumped on this
now so
i'm giving this example it was published
in the lancet which is
the the you know one of the highest
highly rated um scientific articles sort
of journals
i think there's a version of that that
was published someplace else but
so the short of it is that
it was retracted fairly quickly because
you just looked at and you thought how
did you get data from
150 like countries or hospitals and
managed to sort of
standardize the medical coding it's very
complicated
we can't even standardize the medical
coding you know between two kind you
know sort of
hospitals in this country easily let
alone you know hundreds of hospitals
across the world
and hcq has long been shown
since not to have a great upside
but the level of harm because it's a
common drug like it's all
available over the counter like it
wasn't even implausible that you know
maybe it was helpful but the kind of
harm was really high
so i remember like squinting and saying
you found what and it's not really my
field right but because everybody was
sort of pointing this out partly because
they wanted to say
look how terrible trump is right now on
the one hand
trump is has been terrible right so
there's no question like he was just
sort of making
claims he was just basically making
stuff up and it was a dangerous thing to
do
partly because hcq trials have taken up
so much of
our energy when we could have just done
a few trials and been done
right because you know there's some
drugs that work this one isn't
next right like where we tried lots of
things there's another one dexa worked
wonderfully and it's also an
over-the-counter drug
and you know they we found in a trial so
all of that is good
on the other hand this very sort of
prestigious peer-reviewed journal
like what what you just sort of kind of
go what and then
so this is the interesting to me is that
tons of people
kind of said this doesn't make sense
that this is
how it affirmed my faith so there was a
failure clearly by the journal
that the editor like should have just
said
tell me more about this data like you
either gotta because it's such a big
claim
to have collected data that widely that
quickly
uh the peer reviewers should have been
like wait what like there's all these
blind spots and i'm kind of
post talk of course guessing that the
fact that it's
so strongly undermined a trump claim
oh yeah may have helped the blind spot
i'm sure it played a big role uh
yeah so it got through peer review it
got
widely shared and then
here's the part that's great the same
community of scientists
because like i could i was alarmed a
little bit by the data scope because i
kind of have familiarity but like i
don't understand this drug like what do
i know right so i started seeing people
i trust say
this doesn't make sense now i understand
statistics so i started looking at the
statistics and i was like oh this is
made up
because they're like the the um the the
the sort of the adverse event uh
percentages were like with it wasn't
like
point one point two percent across age
groups on like ten different countries
like no way like did you just fill this
up
right you can kind of um i you could do
more
um exact tests but like there's a way to
figure out made-up data and this was
you could even eyeball it and say you
made this up you didn't really need to
bring out the sort of statistical big
guns to
uh figure out the fraudulent data but
i'm just giving this an example of like
stuff
gets through but the good part of
science is then there's a lot of
us who kind of look up and say
wait i don't care that it got through i
don't care it got published in the
highest sort of
rated journal people kind of go and say
this makes sense this doesn't make sense
and it usually takes some time and in
this particular case i think the
retraction happened within weeks
so i think this is kind of like an
example of both the height and depth
like they're both the uh best of times
worst of times like we have these blind
spots
partly due to political polarization
that let a paper that should have been
desk rejected
and um had been seen as a fraud
like immediately
get through partly because it's
undermining uh a president who's
terrible
on the pandemic on the other hand the
scientific community was pretty quick to
say i don't care what
you know you think this is why this is
not wrong and you've got it retracted
so how do you capture that in a bottle
like i don't have a way to say
like what is the process there uh
because you can't just say
trust peer review because i just gave an
example of a massive failure of peer
review
you can't just disregard peer review
because nope
if you don't know anything else about a
topic you know if you have
one assumption to make i'm gonna say
peer review paper is better right like
if i have no other piece of information
that would be my assumption uh but it's
like then what's the next level you know
what does the community say about it
like so that's the thing you can't say
you know a lot of data is good you can't
just
just
it's very hard complicated exactly and
yeah which
fallabilism is a big i think we got a
lot of that kind of complication we saw
a lot of kind of complication in the
pandemic where
as i like to say there's never been a
better time to be um
informed but there's also never been a
worse time to be informed you know it's
both well let's think about the pandemic
uh more broadly because i know that
we've obviously been on about this for
over a year now i've i've seen your
tweets sort of recalling the tweets from
a year ago and shaking
yeah it's been a year about how we
have evolved through this but so we did
get
the pandemic wrong in early days by we i
don't mean you and me necessarily
but the establishment the institutions
the people we're supposed to be able to
trust
the government the media um is there was
there some specific
set of biases or motivations that caused
it to
go wrong or was it just that people were
not trained to think in the right way
about such a complicated problem
so i've been thinking a lot about that
like what happened what went wrong
uh what we could have done so
bunch of things i mean in particular in
the united states we did have the
president
who was a problem right so when you have
the president
basically silencing cdc officials
uh we saw that happened in february so
you have that problem for sure
but i think that hides the bigger
problem
because it wasn't just that
and it wasn't just um the us
like it wasn't just um the europe also
did not do well so one thing i've been
wondering like i was talking to someone
the other day
and i said why didn't the us
universities
like just quickly create a consortium
because we saw in february of 2020 it
was pretty clear that there was going to
be political meddling
uh so why didn't we create our own you
know get the facts
from us consortium like just have um
you know faculties of medicine and
public health
from say you know top 20 30 universities
create like a little expert committee of
ourselves
to you know get the facts on the
pandemic or something like that i think
we could have done that like why why why
didn't we so we didn't react to the
failure of
the authorities when they failed so in
the us so you're already sorry you're
asking why a bunch of
professors did not come together to do
rapid actions i know i know but like we
should have like because the whole
point of the academic institution is
like we're supposed to be doing stuff
like that like
we have this privilege uh of a job that
is supposed to let us do that so we
didn't really do that like at least the
administrations they're always making
strategic plans
and you know doing all this and i'm like
yeah this is a good time but that wasn't
all that failed right so there was a way
in which the politics
failed uh and there was political
meddling but there was i think a lot of
epistemological failures in western
societies too
for one um we didn't take the expertise
from
places with sars experience seriously
because i don't care what you call it
because the world health organization
didn't want to call it
anything like sars because they don't
want to fear scare people but
i mean this is sars basically with
a crucial distinction in that it has
pre-symptomatic spread right
but in a lot of other things it is very
sars had the same age gradient in its
effects it had air aerosol airborne
transmission
it had the over dispersion it is
different pre-symptomatic transmission
it didn't have that but it's a very
similar
kind of coronavirus right um it's
so and the countries that had experience
with it like japan
hong kong taiwan were fairly quick to do
the correct
non-pharmaceutical interventions before
we had more
whereas the western public health i
think was fairly anchored on
waiting for a flu pandemic we think in
flu
and flu is a different pathogen it's not
over dispersed the same way um you kind
of basically
close schools and wait for a vaccine um
like it's not
kids are super spreaders of flu not this
one
um there is like there's not the same
kind of
super spreading behavior anyway in um
flu the same kind whereas this one is
very dependent on
that kind of super spreading events to
drive the epic so there's all these
things that i think we didn't
do we made fun of like masks i've read
so many articles last year
early on uh claiming you know east
asians were
superstitious for wearing masks and i'm
kind of like
you know they have infectious disease
specialists
they have epidemiologists like they're
not just making this up it's not a
talisman like they're these actual
scientists
who um you can talk to before dismissing
you know why is taiwan ramping up
production of um
mask it's a respiratory airborne
pathogen and this is source control this
is not like
you know they're not throwing salt over
their shoulder but i literally read
articles that dismiss that kind of
expertise
uh i think we had a lot of sort of
different
incorrect sort of um reflexes on
trusting the public on like giving the
advice to give yet we gave too many
binary rules
i'm still trying to tell people it's
fine to be outdoors there's no super
spreading events that we know of
outdoors i mean this
is not a mystery it was pretty clear
from the epidemiology of this
disease by march of last year
like by the end of march last year was
pretty clear that
transmission the super spreading
transmission was primarily
occurring indoors in poorly ventilated
places
that outdoor transmission wasn't
impossible but it was pretty high bar
you just didn't see much of it
and super spreading i still don't have
any uh
confirmed you know major daytime super
spreading event like where people are
outside where the photographers take
their picture and then it actually is a
super spreader
like it's been a year but i just saw a
headline
like a front page headline like a week
ago from australia's paper of record
shaming people sitting on a pretty large
beach
for you know breaking quarantine or
whatever it is that
they were being accused of i'm kind of
like you can't be this
behind the scientific knowledge
and this i'm not blaming the ordinary
people because the authorities have been
like not communicating this there's a
huge like i'm kind of going very fast
here but
there was a big fight there's a very big
scientific fight that
i think is gonna play a major role
once this is done it's not getting
enough attention right now because we're
kind of busy with the pandemic itself
in which one of the ways in which the we
set our
npis the non-pharmaceutical
interventions was the
idea that these things this respiratory
pathogen
spread through droplet and if you want
to think in sort of physics terms
droplets are like these ballistic
trajectories they go
they you know you spit them out and they
go down with um
gravity in like a parable they fall to
the ground right so
and aerosols are just small things
that can float around because they're
small and light
now the first people usually call
droplets the second people kind of call
aerosols
right so it turns out and this is going
to be a really interesting sort of
history somebody's going to eventually
write
the world health organization to this
day
has the micron cutoff for what floats
and what falls wrong by a large factor
there's a interesting history to why
this is somebody transcribed something
incorrectly
back when and there's going to be a
paper about it eventually so i don't
want to like
sort of tell all the details till people
have their paper add on so nobody's
really paying attention to this but it's
a major error
because you're basically assuming a mode
of transmission
that now that i kind of step back and
look at it is
probably fairly rare
i think it probably happens like if you
cough or sneeze on someone
like the kind of big drops but most of
it is
floaty stuff now of course the floaty
stuff can float to you
from close range too right it doesn't
mean it's the big stuff that otherwise
would have fallen
right if you're got the floaty aerosol
stuff coming out of your mouth when
you're speaking
uh you are going to be more infected if
you're close to someone
but that's not proof that that is the
big
you know uh ballistic trajectory uh
that because if that were the case you'd
have an
almost an equal amount of outdoor
transmission
you know because stuff if they weren't
just floating around what happens
outdoors
is they get uh they float away very
quickly because air just dilutes them
it's much more windy just aerodynamics
and it turns out one of the sort of our
anchoring biases here was that we
thought most respiratory pathogens are
droplet i think once this
is done we're going to go back and say
well actually most of them were not
like we were wrong in a bunch of stuff
but it didn't really matter because it
wasn't a pandemic and we weren't
checking
sure right so uh so there was these
bunch of people that were like a
minority that were saying
they're aerosols about the other ones
too
and whenever we find a way to check and
it's kind of hard like there's a lot of
these really geeky technical things to
how do you prove it's an aerosol because
it's not easy
like you have to find it here and like
culture a live virus from it or
something like that
so i think this is going to basically
revolutionize our understanding of
how respiratory pathogens actually
transmit most of the time
and the science twist to the story is
that these people have been saying this
kind of yelling in a polite way
at the scientific establishment in the
medical establishment
saying this is how it's happening
we got to pay attention to things that
mitigate
aerosol transmission also for influenza
you know also for this and also for that
and not getting away and when the
pandemic started
that same dogma just wouldn't shift
right
but all of a sudden the stakes were
higher and then all of a sudden we got
more studies
and then all of a sudden you know we got
this major epidemiological record if you
look at the epidemiological records
there is no
other theory of transmission that can
explain that record besides aerosol
transmission being dominant
like to sort of have a story of droplets
doing what we're seeing
clinically in the epidemiological record
of where it's spreading it's
yeah you really have to be a
contortionist to fit that theory fit
that data
but we haven't really had the reckoning
so there's a like i used to think the
kunian idea of
um scientific revolutions was a little
exaggerated for the 21st century i was
kind of like yeah i get it like you know
the newtonian
kind of story i'm like that's a very
cute story but that doesn't happen all
the time like you don't have
these major paradigm shifts uh
and all of that i used to sort of think
that doesn't really happen
a lot because we're a little more
nuanced now like we're not
and we don't have that big shift now i'm
kind of thinking maybe
uh there's more in the making we just
kind of
don't do it plus what i've noticed
in this pandemic is that once it shifts
people really forget like it was almost
misinformation quote unquote a year ago
to say wait it's aerosol
so every right now a lot of people are
like yeah of course it was we said it
was aerosols i'm like
no you know it was kind of like i was
there in those meetings
uh people were accused of making stuff
up and being completely wrong
and stuff like that so there's a way in
which now i think these paradigms just
happen
along with a very sociological process
of amnesia
where the people who were kind of saying
the opposite
they just forget they were saying the
opposite and we kind of move on
without sort of saying oh wait we just
moved on right
this might this is not even terrible in
some sense except
maybe there's a lot more of this than um
i had thought and these paradigm shifts
really are real because i'm just
remembering a year ago sort of staring
at
the screen because we're not in the same
room where
you know people with sort of the aerosol
biophysics would try to explain
your micron cutoff doesn't work here's
the math
that size will not drop and this is
the size that will float and this is the
lab
experiment and this is this like they
would try to explain the stuff
to the medical establishment
and they're just couldn't get anywhere
i think that thomas goon would be very
much on board with the idea that
attention is
more uh a valuable commodity than
information because he was all about how
different people from different
paradigms would look at different pieces
of information and just interpret them
in very different ways
i i thought he like he had more of a my
interpretation was that his story was a
little stylized
like i always thought this is a little
messier but
i'm rethinking that because i think um
part of it is it's really hard to
reconstruct
um where people were saying and all
those things that happened because as
soon as the paradigm shifts
everybody's on the new boat right like
we were always
fighting eurasia kind of thing or
oceania whatever so there's a way in
which that
um that might be thing but yeah so it's
it's
so i think we're gonna like for the me
the pandemic has been a scientifically
very
and sociologically a very interesting
process
to examine because i feel like i've seen
great things i mean we've seen people
kind of
uh you know when the variance of concern
came out i saw sort of labs just do the
neutralization study and just tweet it
out like they didn't even wait for the
paper because they there's this enormous
you know speed and generosity and
like pre-print and pulse print and
you know review and all of those things
it's really been on the one hand
wonderful
on the other hand like there's these
crappy papers like the lancet paper that
i'm like how on earth did that get
through and there's so many now
you know academics and sort of um
epidemiologists and neurologists on
social media now are like
subtweeting each other and blocking each
other like all the social media fights
i'm kind of like
well okay fine you're all human too i
get that but that's kind of
uh um you know and i've seen that of
course it's like very human dynamic i'm
not saying there's
um anything um particularly good or bad
about it so it's kind of like a very
confusing environment
as well because you're seeing great
science great generosity
very interesting thing but if you're
just following this
and you're thinking how do i figure out
you know what's going on
it's pretty hard because there's a lot
of noise
well one thing i don't want to get lost
that you mentioned is
of course there's a whole bunch of cases
and circumstances under which
people are wrong because of
you know their biases or the theoretical
framework they're working in or just
inertia or group think or whatever
but then there's another set of cases
where people
had some knowledge or opinions and then
thought a little overthought the
question of what should we
let other people know right what should
we tell people whether it was the
government or with journalism right like
people were worried too much about what
the effects of saying things might be
and not just the effect
not just worried about getting the truth
out there as quickly as possible
i mean the thing is of course there's a
lot of things in which
uh we got things wrong and then updated
you know and
that's a very noble part of science
right that's perfectly
fine like that's what you're supposed to
do when you get something wrong
and then you go okay like i got it wrong
and here's
what the correct one was like that
you're supposed to do that like
the idea that you wouldn't be wrong
about something is
just nonsense on the other hand of
course you're supposed to look at the
evidence not
what happens to be the guideline from 20
years ago right like you're supposed to
kind of
so i think this is just um like for
somebody interested in the scientific
process i think this has been a very
rich moment but it also shows you that
it is a it is not a magical process it
takes labor
like it takes real work to stay on top
of
any field uh let alone one with such
consequences and it's full of people uh
you know so you have all the human
things well that's good because it lets
me do what i wanted to do anyway which
was just
circle back to the systems thinking that
we started about
at the beginning i mean one of the you
know you drop in some phrases in your
writings that are beloved to me as a
physicist about
non-linear dynamics and phase
transitions and
avalanches and things like that i mean
i love these ideas i can see them in the
dynamics of different things
sometimes i mean how useful are these
concepts to you i mean the idea that
not only do you have a complicated
system in the sense that there's many
moving parts
but that the interactions between the
moving parts are just as important as
the sum of the parts
the thing is i think like uh if you sort
of look at sort of complex
um systems or systems thinking or
whatever you want to call it these
things you see a lot of examples clearly
from physics
you know this is um so much of it you
see it in sort of
any kind of ecology or environment kind
of you look at like ecological studies
and things like that you see all these
very interesting sort of
interactions and one of the things that
i was struggling with in the early days
of the pandemic was trying to explain
non-linear dynamics
right because epidemics are very
non-linear dynamics
and people were like you know can you
come up with a metaphor and i'm like
you don't really go through them in your
own
like macro life like you don't you have
them in your body perhaps but you don't
really have a lot of macro processes
that you observe this
but you do in like social media where um
social media
like it grows very fast if you're kind
of like an early mover
because it's an exponential process it's
like a network that just kind of grows
and i think that's one of the reasons
why the um silicon valley people were
quick to this
because they're used to looking for
exponential processes
that will make them rich right you know
it's the other way around whereas this
is an exponential process that will make
life terrible for all of us
so you need to kind of figure out how do
you because with an exponential process
you get in early or you get overwhelmed
right like the steep part of the
exponential is not
a place you're going to very gently surf
you just need to
go first so like things like the
nonlinear dynamics i've always found
fascinating because of
you know how they are everywhere but
non-intuitive
uh so you can't cut you know there's
only so many times you can give that
uh chess pieces and rice example
yeah yeah everybody gives the same you
know you put one rice on the chess board
and then two like i'm like well you
might as well give the math there's
nothing intuitive
about that because people don't usually
do you don't do that in your normal life
but i think right now with epidemics
people might have finally gotten a bit
of an intuition
so face transitions for example like
they are i'm not making
a direct sort of math um
sort of analogy there but you can think
of what we're talking about as these
paradigm shifts where you kind of go
from
you know everybody thinks one way and
then we sort of switch
um you can see it in um some of the ways
in which once there's enough like this
is a very over dispersed epidemic
in that there's like little peaks that
are very crucial to the
way it's super spreading but once you
have a lot of community transmission so
that it's everywhere
for a while it looks like flu yeah
because it's so
widespread that like it'll kind of keep
going
uh in different ways it's almost it's
not really a phase transition but it
um like that's a good intuitive way of
describing it to somebody who
understands phase transition some things
like that
so i find those kinds of uh ways of
thinking to be
really useful in understanding
where things are right now for example
we have a lot of convergent evolution
in the mutations which has surprised
the virologists like in people we
weren't expecting
this and there's a lot of sort of
fascinating discussions but
because there's a very particular
mutation that's
popping up everywhere and
it is like making things more
transmissible
among other things it may not be
happening because it's making things
more transmissible that might be
something that's coming along for the
ride
there might be something else driving it
so it's making me think for example
about
um like convergent evolution is a very
interesting complex systems dynamic
where you have a very large sort of
potential fitness landscape but strict
optimization criteria and
will it converge every time you do it or
is it very sort of contingent and
stochastic and it'll go all sorts of
different places and it's kind of
looking like
um under certain conditions there's
strong
pressure for convergence uh
because the same mutation because we
didn't really like
i honestly like i i followed this the
whole time
almost everybody was surprised by the
number of places the same
few mutations
popped up like clearly it's adaptive
it's like it's not the kind of thing
that
because you can see it take over the
other variant like you see this
particular mutation you know go eat the
available space so i think we're going
to learn a lot about how do you think
about
something like that because it's not
just a question of urology
it also means that well that means that
if we leave this alone
this is what's going to happen like this
is um
you know this kind of convergent
evolution that it's finding the sort of
local maxima almost
everywhere uh we're going to see it in
lots of places and how do we prepare for
it
so these are interesting ways of
thinking about it now unfortunately
usually these are languages that are not
spoken across fields
sociologists don't talk about convergent
evolution
or like it's you hear it from all the
biology people but you don't really hear
it from the other things but i find them
all
they show up they come up like they come
up in the world the world isn't siloed
into
these um fields so i mean this
leads me to the perfect final question
which is too big to possibly be answered
but
what do you have in having
learned a bunch over the last year about
uh
pandemics and so forth not just you but
the world what does this tell us about
the next pandemic there's a lot of ways
in which this virus could have been
worse
right but yeah maybe we're better at
fighting it now i don't know
so i there i've been like sort of uh
there's a couple of things to say one of
them is that
while it's tragic i mean there's no
question like we had half a million
deaths in the united states so there's
no way to
kind of dismiss this in the
potential
pathogenscape let's say this is a mild
one
uh it kills a relatively low
compared to many others uh it is
very targeting it's targeted by age i
mean it's of course a tragedy to have
the elderly die but it would have been a
very different
conversation if the you know
fatality rate for children was 10
instead of
for people over 80 i mean i of course i
don't want
people over 80 to
die prematurely but it's a really
different societal effect if it's
you know children uh where if it kills
you know one in ten who got infected or
something like that that would be a very
different thing
uh and it's also while we screwed it up
it's very susceptible to
non-pharmaceutical interventions exactly
because it's over dispersed and
very much you know so if you kind of
control the indoor super spreading in
crowded places
you get a big bang for your buck
so what's next question option number
one
we get something similar we get like you
know sars mars
three and we know what to do
and like we kind of go back to our
playbook uh
and then we're like doing well
uh that's option one option two uh we
get
a flu which we prepared for so long
and then you know wasn't the right thing
and then we adapted finally to sars mars
and we get another influenza pandemic
and then
then people are saying oh we don't
really need to care about formats and
hand washing whereas that's going to be
very important and kids are going to be
super sweaty so that's also possible too
like
so what i think is what we should learn
is to be
very sensitive to early data right like
what do you like when you don't know
what you got like i'm all for
being extra cautious like in february of
2020 i would have been like
do everything because we don't know
what's coming down the pike like just
the precautionary principle totally
applies if you have an exponential
threat
but once you learn you have to adjust oh
it's over dispersed oh it's indoors
oh it's this right so you have to do
that so i think the next time something
comes what's going to happen is like
the lessons will be not do the same act
fast but be very responsive to data
early on
right because it really depends on what
do we have
and no guarantee is what we're gonna get
people have a difficult time saying or
listening to people say
i don't know now but a week from now i
will know so ask me like they they think
they want to know the answer right away
or you're untrustworthy yeah sometimes
it's difficult
no and like it's better to say we don't
know so we're going to do everything
while we figure it out
i think it's a good motto for living our
lives all right zayn neptune fetchy
thank you very much for being on the
windscape
thank you for inviting me
[Music]
you